all right we do want to keep you aware
of other developments this week we've
not forgotten the uh obviously that
there were some very big developments
this week including along the border
with the administration was growing
about some numbers that show those
migrants coming from countries like Cuba
Nicaragua Haiti and Venezuela well those
cases drop prohibitively uh about 97
down to a seven day average of about 115
in the latest period uh in January
versus uh obviously
3367 in the last seven day average in
December now what that does not include
though are all those from all countries
better than 130 and there the numbers
are much more numbing and about north of
000 so-called gotaways or those
apprehended at the border to say nothing
of those who were never captured
something that I raised with the Texas
governor uh Greg Abbott earlier this
week
foreign
you're a very informed person and we're
misled by the president the average
American is completely misled by the
president who I think purposefully
issued misleading information to make it
look to the public like there was some
decrease on the border he's wrong for
two reasons one of which you pointed out
and that is they're talking about these
four different countries Americans need
to know there are people coming across
the border from more than
140 different countries and so he's he's
admitting a large number of people
coming from across the entire world
second thing as was reported in is a
fact and that is this time of year is
the lowest time of year for border
crossings and so this is just seasonal
and if nothing else happens there will
be the natural increase in February and
March escalating all through the
summertime but then to add to this
Biden's new border policy is actually
going to be attracting even more people
to enter into the United States
illegally and so Biden is doing nothing
but sowing chaos which is exactly why
Republicans in the United States House
of Representative need to put the pedal
to the medal to make sure that they stop
any type of program like this and by the
by the demonstration you know Governor
you mentioned this period is is one that
tends to be slower now we know already
in December for the total month there
were record number of encounters 251 487
do you then suppose that number when the
January numbers are tallied and the
aggregate will also be smaller
we'll see uh and again there's so many
asterisks involved because as was
reported which is accurate and that is
there are so many godaways that are not
reported in the official numbers issued
by the federal government how many of
these Governor are influenced by this
deal we have of Mexico to deal with
Asylum cases to the tune of adjudicating
them on their side of the Border uh to
the tune of about 30 000 a month it
might be too early to start digesting
this or tabulating this but what do you
think
so it is too early as that program goes
into place it's my analysis and the
analysis of others uh that that is
actually going to increase the number of
people coming across the border the
reason is because the body
Administration is basically granting
parolee status to these people who are
coming across the border illegally and
all that will do is to Spur even more
people to rush the Border thinking that
they too will get parolee status but to
be clear what the bad Administration is
doing is flat out contrary to federal
law federal law does not allow this Mass
parolee process it requires any
president executive branch to issue
parole on only a case-by-case basis and
so we the state of Texas we filed a
lawsuit to put a stop to this program by
the by demonstration because it is
clearly unequivocally against the law
you know um Governor if you don't mind
my going back to the president's visit
at the border I and his initial meeting
with you I believe at the airport and it
strikes me as that was a limited meeting
um and after that I think you gave him a
letter to explain what was going on he
claimed not to have read it hours later
can you tell us a little bit about that
sure first to be clear that was the
eighth letter that I've sent to the
president about the Border I have
received no response whatsoever but to
make sure that he knew what was in the
letter you showed on your show and other
shows uh a period of time when I was
visiting with him there at the El Paso
Airport and I wanted to make sure he
knew there was one key component of that
letter I have five bullet points in that
letter that he can ensure that he uses
current law not new law but current law
to enforce the border to stop illegal
immigration from occurring and I said
it's time for you as president of the
United States to step up and do your job
and enforce these laws that already
exist to stop the illegal flow of people
coming across our border so it looked
like a single page Governor um so there
wasn't much to it I I'm not saying not
much substantly to it I didn't mean it
like that but that it was a quick read
anyone could read that quickly and hours
later we're told that the president
president still had not what did you
make of that
right so we we purposefully put it on
one page to make sure it wasn't a long
document that would be long and
complicated for him to read I talked to
the first couple of paragraphs about the
chaos that he's caused in the country
and in Texas uh and about the ways that
he's violated his oath of office in the
Constitution and then I made those Five
Points about what it needs to do and
he's just ignoring all of this and
federal law and imposing his own will
and policies which are open border
policies allowing these people to come
in from more than 140 countries across
the globe as you know many of your
critics Governor including those in the
White House said it was a political
stunt what you did with the letter and
all was a political stunt what do you
think of that
so because I had previously sent him
seven letters and got no response I
figured I had to be there in person to
hand in the eighth letter to try to get
a response from him he did say at the
time uh that he would you know try to
work with us but of course we've heard
nothing from him and so the only thing
that is a stunt is is what the president
is doing to allow people to come into
the United States contrary to United
States law with no accountability for
the president so um I know you're in a
wheelchair sir and you've done a very
effective job as Governor dealing with
that and now entering your third term
was there any understanding that because
of that you wouldn't be able to actually
tour the border with the president there
are a lot of paved areas where I think
that could have been accommodated who
decided that that meeting at the airport
would be it
uh the body Administration to to be
clear the vitaministration had announced
days before my meeting with him uh that
they were going to El Paso but it wasn't
until late the night before he arrived
uh that they sent an email to a lower
level person into my Administration that
got up to my chief of staff uh to invite
me to meet the president at the tarmac
at the airport with no invitation to do
anything else with him listen I've I've
been with the former president of the
United States President Trump on the
border and as Governor I've been on
every component of the border so I can
get around on rocks on roads on dirt
whatever the case may be so there was
nothing stopping the president from
including me with him other than the
fact he did not want to detract from his
message remember this last thing Neil
and that is El Paso at the instruction
of the Bible Administration completely
cleaned up all of the the migrants who
were sleeping on the streets in El Paso
to sanitize
president would not say anything out of
place
so it was the border patrol it was the
border patrol who were asked to do that
the president of the United States took
border patrol off the border to clean up
the streets of El Paso got it real
quickly so your name keeps coming up and
a growing list of potential Republican
Governors who might entertain a White
House run so I thought well I had you
here and you were a captive audience you
would answer that one way or the other
are you going to run for president
Neil I'm focused on one thing and that's
being governor of the great state of
Texas
all right because the governor of New
Hampshire said the same thing just
re-elected governor in the great state
of New Hampshire I I I've heard that out
of uh Governor Kemp in Georgia
re-elected loves the great state of
Georgia they all kind of have that in
common and then they run
um I'm not saying they are is it fair to
say that you want to and prefer to stay
in Texas for these next four years
rather than make a White House run
so the only accurate thing to say Neil
is that my focus is only on leading the
great state of Texas
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight